our body is bombarded by several
pathogens every day
and these pathogens include viruses
bacteria
fungi helminth etc and in this video we
would look at
how our body deals with bacterial
infection
so stay tuned till the end of this video
because we would learn in details that
how our immune system
respond against a bacterial infection
in order to understand this phenomena
better let us take a
real time example so let's say you have
accidentally stepped on a rusty nail
and this rusty nail has breached your
first line of defense that is your
physical barrier the skin
with this rusty nail there was a lot of
bacteria which has invaded
your body so right now body's immune
system should recognize
and fight back these bacterias so
first line of defense is the inner
immune cells
inner immune cells would then and there
go to the site of infection or site of
damage and try to recognize these
bacteria
the major immune in it immune cells
which
takes part to fight
bacterial infection are neutrophil
macrophages dendritic cell etc
now these inner immune components
try to engulf these bacteria and
eliminate them
not only that these macrophages or
dendritic cell they would secrete
chemical messengers known as chemokine
which would attract
many more macrophages or inner immune
cells to the site of infection
and it would mount a stronger immune
response
against these invaders
now let us look at a particular
dendritic cell the dendritic cell
it's a phagocytotic cell just like the
macrophage
so it would engulf the bacteria and then
the bacterial endosome would fuse
with lysosomes and eventually
the bacteria would be damaged and
neutralized
inside these phagolysosomes the
debris or these components would be
eventually displayed on the dendritic
cell surface
on class 2 mhc molecules using class 2
mhc molecules
dendritic cell present these antigens to
t
helper cells now dendritic cells would
now mobilize
towards the army base camp that is
the lymph node now inside the lymph node
there are dedicated
regions where you would find t cells and
b cells
these dendritic cells can activate t
cells and thereby activating b cells
or depending upon the bacteria the
bacteria can
itself activate the b cell directly via
endotoxins we would learn about both
so in this particular example a t
cell is activated by the dendritic cell
and now it would activate several b
cells when the b cells are activated
they would eventually become plasma
cells which would generate antibody
and for long term defense many of these
b cells would
proliferate inside the germ germinal
center
and ultimately they would also
differentiate into antibody secreting
plasma cells so
there could be activation of b cells
either in a t cell independent manner or
a dependent manner
so many bacteria has endotoxins
which are part of their
cell wall or cell membrane component
like such as lps
so these endotoxins can activate b cells
without
the help of any t cell no matter how the
b cell would be activated the ultimate
goal is to proliferate
and make antibodies so the b cells would
proliferate
and increase in number ultimately these
naive b cells would be
gaining experience and ultimately become
plasma cells which would secrete
different isotypes of antibody against
that particular bacteria now once these
antibodies are
produced these antibodies can coat the
bacteria
and optimize these bacteria or other
word is to neutralize these bacteria
so it would make it difficult for this
bacteria to affect other cell types in
the body
moreover there are many cell types in
the immune system
such as macrophages neutrophils
dendritic cells or nk cells
which has receptors
against these fc portion of these
antibodies
so they can bind to that particular
antibody
and engulf the pathogen and this is
known as
antibody dependent cellular cytotoxicity
by this particular response body can
fight back bacteria
now apart from these kind of responses
body can also fight by producing
complement proteins these complement
proteins would also coat the bacteria
and optionalize them many complement
proteins associated with each other and
forms a membrane attack complex which
lead to fluid leakage
now this would lead to a osmolarity
disbalance and
bursting of the bacteria moreover these
complement proteins could also work like
a
anaphyla toxin these antiflow toxins are
soluble molecule which can
work like chemo attractant and overall
evoc inflammatory response
so these anaphyla toxins help in
immune cell extraversation such as this
particular neutrophil
would be now moving through this
blood capillary and it would reach the
tissue space
to fight the bacteria and this kind of
chemo attractive signal
is really important for engaging more
and more
immune components against that
particular bacteria
so in this video we learned that
antibody dependent cellular cytotoxicity
complement mediated lysis or generating
antibody are several ways by which our
body
fight backs bacterial infection but in
the next video we will talk about how
bacteria
can act in a clever fashion and
prevent destruction
by our immune system so stay tuned till
the next video
but if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe
and you can also support my uh journey
in patreon
and you can access my courses in an
academy which is
india's biggest learning platform and
using my code ap 10 you can get a 10
discount and do let me know in the
comment how you like my videos thank you